we see you outside this is a ridiculous
stupid game this game so stupid
[Music]
all right there all right I got a
broadcast okay
Oh squad did you you look like the rock
I look like who's the Korean I look like
that came from Las yeah yeah that's
right yeah Craig why you a girl I always
make my characters after Kitty so you
can watch them get my ready up ready up
over my back a bad mother
it's a CEF our OS that's my twitch it
but you don't need to watch it it's just
embarrassing
yeah well it's Steve dreamless okay
streaming yeah damn the viewers dropped
dramatically had to read you because we
had to switch out so the thing ended you
know yeah you know you know you'll be
good
you
any of you guys said new 50 shades of
gray second I think my mom wants to
cheer up she read that book and I know
chicks love aged women III yeah I was
joking I don't know I really watch that
yeah yeah I don't carry who wants lead
okay okay let me just say this right now
Steve when you revive someone or if
someone's trying to revive you don't
move okay don't
okay where we going vulgar when we drop
it where we drop me still early silent
hey Steve hey three two one to tell
Steve another president yeah yeah no I
know I know okay
no yet not yet
any day now 3 2 1 jump oh I didn't press
it you know where you guys are
do you follow us okay Steve
yeah just follow us I'm gonna go these
houses right here straight below pretty
much right there
land land land whoa whoa Pikachu no
relax bro we had just started this holy
well I got I got a car I got a car all
right well I see how much your [ __ ]
forms don't go to the other house on the
other side in these houses form already
this is drives me nuts dude I know it's
really Pikachu you're just gonna crash
the van smart so smart house car for you
Miami but I have no [ __ ] gun are we
on the same who's getting shot at is
anybody opposed there we go someone's
getting shot at or just picking [ __ ] up
how do you reload again hold X well that
this is all I don't look at play this
key
oh there it is that's why I didn't have
the ammo okay I got a gun make sure you
put your [ __ ] to full auto if you have a
machine gun okay I'm still grabbing some
on our last game of pug G okay okay okay
I'm sorry I was my girl
anybody where's the zone Peaks check out
the zone tell us what it's looking like
we're good we're in the zone
we're perfect code you okay so let's not
go crazy just like equipo it Cooper we
got a clip where you guys at
I'm in this house over here I'm trying
to find a backpack and a vest if there
is one you guys might have already
raided this [ __ ] we're coming all right
I gotta drop this oh my job to see my
doc I still can't get the [ __ ]
suppressor stop honking stupid they
don't honk what are you doing who's that
watch out for the raw mean do you learn
how Drive Jesus Christ
hmm don't worry everything always works
out yeah I'm not to shoot you no no eh
okay oh my god I'm jumping out alright
don't [ __ ] around we only got one game
stupid idiot I know I know
I didn't go just check anything else
just around here just in case there's
stuff cuz we're gonna have to go to
zones and start running like crazy soon
yeah police faster ammo okay there's a
plane drop I don't know it's above us
shoot oh my god that's a plane yeah
that's a drop okay I wish there's a
[ __ ] backpack see it gas can bunch of
[ __ ] sidearm [ __ ] Oh Craig the houses
that came from head back back soon
there was like two backpacks well that's
get in the car is that you or somebody
else just Pikachu alright [ __ ] I needed
a backpack alright [ __ ] it let's go want
a vest we've still got a minute fifty
dude I'm gonna put a marker here in the
middle I got a vest
I need iron I couldn't use the backpack
I'm right here just just clear out what
you need I don't know I'm just gonna get
in the car I'm coming
I don't know like we don't have time you
get weapons stop honking yes your stop
honking why would you do that you just
purposely want to die
oh no I'm coming I'm coming on come on I
feel like I shouldn't be driving on the
car yeah you should I'll Drive I'll
Drive so you gotta be navigator
yeah I marked the new spot well who's
driving still Pikachu but still I am
your best stop just go just go to the
blue marker all right here I'll get out
I'll take go let me go let me go yeah
move over black just blackness oh hi
everybody ready all right let's go to
the blue marker they're shooting at us
because some dumbass decided to honk the
horn and shoot no that was me a shot
that's cool I'm gonna keep going until
we get more centered I'm gonna keep
going till we get more centered yeah
yeah see cuz a restricting play area I
don't want to be that guy on the
outskirts oh [ __ ] what is up here watch
outside I know that's why I'm coming
around it so tight I don't know if a car
shooting at us don't I'll peek out
you're gonna yeah no [ __ ] - yeah I know
from experience
all right they were rockin around you
straw
how are we still go to the house for
your backpack I mean I'm gonna try it
whoa it's just it's fishtailing hold up
we're trying to get us more centered
dude oh this is way to play this game
you know here's the middle here's the
middle oh my god is so dizzy stop it
I'm going to the Green Dot dude that's
where that's where I said it that's the
middle of nowhere
that's no way just go just go go go go
go
come here let's get in this house we're
in the middle I'm trying to Center us
dude why is never in the center that's
why it's gonna get smaller in Mahler and
far away yeah I'd be careful Center
Curtis might have been raided Shh
there's gas cans up here grenades will
need guests kids I know I don't know
what then you know are we all all right
I read some starting not nearest I got a
protection I think I think we should
start a hit like chilling somewhere
where we could be there's a police mess
here I'll take the bandages I got the
bandages Steve did you get a police vest
yet yeah I got I'm wearing one okay
banana yeah I come with you Steve be
careful going along dude all right I'm
gonna start closing in I say we find a
spot and stay stay tight cuz we get more
gear we still gotta get more here we
have no yeah but what yeah I got an okay
yeah you do
I'm just telling you I mean what I could
use a backpack but
Craig yeah I'm coming I'm coming wait
wait whose car is that look that's me
I'm in the vehicle where I'm on the map
I'm coming to me oh [ __ ] Frank's here
hey what's up Frank
oh there he is hi Frank Pikachu get out
the dogs allowed you're making noise
gonna there's gonna be our last game cuz
we've been playing for a long ass while
done know from I'm just gonna play a few
matches them sorry
no worries all right I got a backpack
search the houses get loot all right
what if we just grab water something
small like this house dude yeah but it
doesn't always finish in a house
sometimes no no no we gotta start we got
to start we got to start like boning up
somewhere like we want to start getting
there but we're on an ammo like all I
have is shotgun all right all right
we need more you need more guns not
animals what you're saying yeah well
here dude I got [ __ ] right here
come downstairs yeah like there's
[ __ ] two shotguns hey Steve come in
this room where I am
there there right there Steve there's an
ACP right here daddy's got a UMP he's
got a UMP yeah oh oh so much [ __ ]
gunshots get in here get in you're
closed door get in this get guys buckle
up in this house let's go upstairs
actually again this house go upstairs go
upstairs dude you're wearing shorts I
mean my underwear oh my controller hey
hello are you guys still there my
controller dawg oh hello batteries oh my
god dude he's gonna die we don't need
them anymore
so we just and user well yeah I mean
we're in the middle code yeah let's just
stay here dude it's gonna get hairy it
doesn't want to really stay in the
center of the map I know dude but but
like what's the point of just moving
around randomly for no reason to get
more leader people shooting we got might
have been our gun it wasn't he always
gotta keep moving - oh thank you Frank
see ya keep moving guys
we're gonna get murdered dude I know
that's what's gonna happen
ya see ya gonna get murdered a few times
alright there's running around got and
he's dead
hey no no I down to other place I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
you guys cover my bags buddy cover my
back oh no he's hurt
Steve holding hands I'm not an taptic
not working oh you just have to tell me
I'm doing it I'm looking out for
intruders hey someone loot loot their
ammo look their stuff what are they I
don't know where's the guy you killed
right here the box the box right here oh
[ __ ] they got a lot of [ __ ] dude oh I'm
winning where these punk glasses
anyone got hey you know I got first aid
for Arthur I got this first day right
there how do I get into the ER thing Oh
shots shots
I'm reloading on a gun I don't know I'm
going in this house to stay maybe I'm
coming in here close these doors
yeah let's go take a shoot yeah I'll
take a [ __ ] at the factor we got this
bathroom covered how do I get on my
belly hole to use your house which
motorcycle more SEC outside oh there's
two okay boom bro
yeah piggie cheese gonna get us killed
it
no I need some of the living room why
are you guys hiding in that room Shh all
right go ahead I'm coming I'm coming
run away oh that scared me
I hold on you could choose coming in to
get you
it's not me That's not me oh [ __ ] we see
you outside this game so stupid
we're gonna have to go we're gonna have
to go more center how's it how's the
truck looking it got shot up a little
bit it could explode okay I'm getting to
the truck let's go let's go still I'm
stopping go get in get in
I mean let's go hold up I'm getting some
stuff come on man guys now you do we're
gonna get shot get in here do this
hellish [ __ ] on the box yeah I know
alright let's go hey somebody put a
marker to the mid Maps TV get in get in
do you want to go to the shelter
I want to go mid mid map mid map figure
out where I'm in prison
we'll put appointment what where is it
okay it's probably prison yeah I'm in
the vehicle okay what color okay blue
all right it's yellow yellow yellow
yellow
okay if we get shot at and we get out of
the car cuz it's cars about to explode
you should get out the car you'll run
over and die try to run someone over
okay
how close is this this looks pretty good
right here is this bar these buildings
good should we alright let's read houses
all right be careful though be careful
there could be people in here I'll go in
first
oh [ __ ]
Jesus Bolger speaker so supposedly
someone said you hear less maybe you
have notions ya know if you have shoes
on they make a loud sound but then to
make less sound if you don't have shoes
on it's also if you're all not wearing
shoes you can easily hear someone who is
and you can just be like oh okay no
one's coming please a lot he plays a lot
of it all right let's hole up in one of
these houses dude
does anyone have 762 they need it I have
some painkiller I got some stuff for us
okay there'll be a [ __ ] out
there I got an Uzi a police vast nine
millimeter up here okay no painkillers
how we doing man we're at least forty
seventh place yeah we're really good
someone you
Luzi so I know anything in here you get
an energy drink are you got one oh hey
when you do that that's okay at least
I'm not honking the horn Oh what do we
do here either I don't start them all
right should we just hold it like where
are we in the map we're pretty sad we're
in the Sun I say we just yeah I say we
hold this stay on top level stay out of
windows don't [ __ ] around
I do what I'm doing I'm clouds to the
backside yeah but you're outside you
don't need to be outside I hear I hear
that's me that's I just said I'm moving
the vehicle to the back side if we need
a move we just run all right I got this
closed up too we should be we should be
stationed here cuz they can only come in
I think this one door right you guys
yeah I'm checking this hey I'm just
saying like here let's close this
because they can only come through this
one before they can only come through
this door
okay Steve look at me in my eyes it's
the game just give it to all right
there's gunshots bro yeah that's why
we're chilling in here they have to open
the doors coming toward us cards coming
toward us all right yeah day long I
should begin on the second floor oh who
is it that's a man's ears they drove off
that you're off we're good
yeah but we're centered dude look get up
here I don't know what you guys are
doing your
like I want to be out there Rambo you
guys are gonna get murked
can they shoot through these windows you
can throw [ __ ] through the windows well
they can shoot but oh dad
Pikachu's coming upstairs yeah just just
close the door and let's just stay here
cuz they're gonna have to come in this
way Craig Craig hey you're my line of
sight here I decide Oh OOP they're
trying to draw us out I dropped a whole
bunch of shell
it can only come through this door and
let's do a magic ladder or something I
don't [ __ ] know there's it let's pick
it you outside so making me nervous
they're closed - they're closed - oh
they're coming in where well they're
there to our left I'm sure they if
they're gonna come in this house they're
gonna come through this door Arthur
don't go through that door we'll shoot
don't move don't move as you can hear
I'm climbing up the stairs and if we
don't move move your marker from the map
[Music]
press why why yeah hey we're doing
pretty good we're like centered I heard
something it could be coming from
downstairs
no it's good because then if they come
then you guys will know yeah I mean we
didn't happen okay thank you
close the door yeah just don't shoot
each other that's it don't shoot each
other so we have to wait is that what it
is we're just waiting now yeah cuz my
god right outside the mat well we got we
got we got time pull right outside the
map don't move don't move you guys make
so much noise anymore hey guys I need
heal up and we'll run downstairs to grab
the bandage oh [ __ ] we are out of the
circle yeah I know but don't we don't
have to go yet we don't have to go yet
yeah I just said anything serious grab
bandages this is when he gets murdered
it's like every movie I think I left the
stove on
oh there's a [ __ ] Jeep up here yeah
oh he see us you saw me dude
yep tell you oh there they know we're
here
I saw a guy up there right close that
door close that door close no I'm here
they know I'm here
Jeep where I just get in here dude I
just oh oh Jesus Christ what did I say
from where there on the hill dude you're
on the hill were you shooting or where
they shooting me I did not sir the
window they're shooting us through the
window dude let's see if I can scope him
with my gun
so I'm downstairs laying on the ground
waiting for them to come in they know
we're here I'm just gonna take a nap
here on the mile arm this mattress
don't push me dude you just pushed me
right into the [ __ ] line of fire dude
Jesus Christ
I so wanna [ __ ] shoot Pikachu so how
do you throw grenades man like how do
you do this [ __ ] I think press right
yeah press right select the grenade okay
press right button yeah right on the
d-stick are we told you the guys making
so much noise
let's go [ __ ] this is not good dude
they're gonna be in these houses I feel
like are we getting our car oh where is
that coming from
that was me sorry is that coming past
only shot sorry going
Arthur they're coming all right get in
the car
hey man Oh God stop stop
go go go go we'll get shot flip around
flip around go get the guys and you're
leaving us boys coming friend is that
Stephen them [ __ ] us or what no hey
play a game later oh we gotta go we
gotta go get in get in the car to the
right all the way to the car so go there
you go
I go left go left go left wait Steve
please stop real quick watch out there's
a [ __ ] car right there dude our cars
about to explode just keep going
straight go straight
how did I die in the car [ __ ] all right
you got to get out there oh there's a
guy straight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]